[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
it's Sunday Funday you are locked into
the right place this is the V our
vetting show presented by the Caesars
Palace sports book if you're following
us on social @ vr underscore betting you
got my Thursday night winner with the
Titans Jags under I've got more of my
week three picks starting right now
[Music]
welcome back to the bee our vetting show
alongside our vetting inside of the
lovely and talented Kelli Stewart I'm
cabby Richards you know Kelly there are
no guarantees in life but there's so
many people here in the sports book that
are guaranteeing victories for the
Patriots and the Cowboys this week two
different betters had moneyline parlays
on Dallas and New England one guys
ticket who spent a thousand bucks to win
45 and another dude dropped 89 grand to
win for Y though cabbie I'd love to win
four grand today but not at the expense
of eighty nine thousand dollars these
are kind of the opposite of what I do in
college football where it's a little to
win a lot these are a lot to win a
little the only logical explanation is
maybe casino comps I don't get it and
listen I I know that they're not betting
in the way that you do because these are
overwhelming favorites and we know you
love your underdogs they make things
interesting
I love the plus money what do you want
from me okay all right so let's get to
our marquee matchups of the week
starting with the as you say the ugliest
dog of the week that our that is the
Miami Dolphins who are going to douse
they are 22 and a half point underdogs
Kelly will you bet on this game Kelly I
just can't do it listen the math says
the Dolphins is probably the right side
this one opened at 17 got as high as 23
do you want to touch the dumpster fire
that is the Dolphins I mean I stopped
the Dolphins ten of their last 11 losses
I've been by double-digits but then on
the flip side you have this Cowboys team
off big divisional wins over the Giants
and the Redskins their sentence fat and
sassy in Dallas this weekend all they
have to do is beat the Dolphins they
have the Saints on deck plus Jason
Garrett one in six against a spread as a
home favorite of eight points or more
kaby I'd lean towards the Dolphins here
but there's no way I'm betting this with
my own money okay well when you lean
towards a team does that mean you're
gonna bet on the team no it means like
if you were asking me to have an opinion
I'm leaning towards the side of the
Dolphins but again until they've shown
me something they haven't yet this
season there's no way I can put my
hard-earned money on then okay fine all
right let's lean back lean back to New
York and I don't know how Fat Joe feels
about the quarterback situation with the
Jets as they have two quarterbacks with
the last names Faulk and
sailes the New York Jets they traveled
to Foxborough they are 21 point
underdogs will you bet on this one did
you see my hashtag on Monday night when
I was filming the Jets plus six and a
half ticket Faulk my life and that is
exactly how Jets backers have to feel we
talked about this week one I'm not
betting against this Patriots team at
home I just can't do it thirteen and
three against the spread their last 16
home games this is an interesting
divisional game the Jets usually play
tough but good news for the guy who bet
almost 90 grand bets Pats are six and Oh
straight up but what I do like here
cabby all six of those games have went
under the total I like the under 43 ok
so let's move on to someone with giant
expectations that daniel Jones era
begins at quarterback Eli Manning has
been benched in Week three the Giants
take fight there are five point
underdogs and they go to Tampa Bay how
do you see this game and will you bet on
the Giants so this is the question I
have for you okay Eli Manning Dana Jones
who's the better quarterback well one
has Hall of Fame credentials Eli Manning
and the other dude got booed in
Tennessee when he was drafted by the
Giants Oh fair enough lead well present
date UI and daniel Jones there's
actually no drop off this line move is a
huge overreaction we saw this get as
high as six and that is where I'm
recommending we take the Giants we've
now seen it come down to five that's
called reverse line movement that's
going in our favor why because the sharp
guys like the Giants the Bucs
six and twelve against the spread in the
last 18 games is a home favorite I know
Jameis Winston got it done for me
against the Panthers just a couple of
Thursday nights ago but there's no way
I'm laying points with this team cabbie
Giants to play oh wow okay alright and
and finally the marquee matchup of the
week this game features a couple of NFL
cheat codes in Lamar Jackson versus
Patrick LaVon mahomes the second at
quarterback for the Dead City Chiefs the
Baltimore Ravens are five and a half
point underdogs as they go to Arrowhead
it's pouring rain right now will you how
will you bet in this game yeah cabbie
it's crazy if you put both of these guys
and stats up next to each other they
look like mirror images of one another
except Lamar has some more rushing yards
because he's a dual threat quarterback
both seven touchdowns no interceptions
it's gonna be such
an awesome game but I'm gonna make you
wait to talk about it what do you mean
you're gonna delay our gratification
it's my best bet so we have to just wait
a little bit Kelly I need Jackson versus
mahomes plunged into my veins
immediately or into my eyeballs like I
can't I can't wait for your best bet I'm
sorry you just have to wait patience is
a virtue is that one mom used to say mom
did say that among some other she had
some other choice words all right in the
meantime we have some fans from the
sports book that want to sell you on
their best bets
whichever can convince Kelly to bet with
them win some BR swag our first
gentleman on the stage is hi Jason
where're you from
yes okay alright what is your best bet
for this beautiful and it's all Sunday
the Bengals you like the bangles why I
do well they came back and beat a
depleted Jets defense they beat a Giants
offense with absolutely no star power
the the Bengals are just the better pick
today I'm just tryin do you don't like
the Bengals as I mentioned week one Andy
Dalton against the spread September's an
absolute beast plus 8 and 2 against the
spread their last 10 is a road underdog
going out with cow because I like your
Bengals pick come on over what's all
these Cowboys jerseys ok good grief this
is too much for me all right are you
betting that what's your name I'm sorry
my name is Alfredo nice to meet you
where are you from here Las Vegas ok
it's very nice all right
are you betting on your Cowboys today
yeah I am and also the Texans on the /
and the Chargers game ok why do you like
that over man I just think it's gonna be
an exciting game a lot of points scored
and I'm just doing it for the sport no
concern about last week both really
low-scoring Affairs Texans Jags and
Chargers at the Lions yeah well you know
that's where I'm at all right
life's too short Sabet the under I guess
Chargers 11 in five to be over in
September over the last four seasons I
kind of liked that play as well all
right last but not least hi what's your
name Matt Matt where you from Vegas okay
all right we got Vegas in the house
today
now what's your favorite NFL bet uh
today I'm gonna be doing Rams we were -
three-and-a-half okay is there
where you like the ramps I mean just
overall I got a lot of friends from you
know Ram country and just loving those
people so I mean I kind of grew up with
them so I'm just kind of came along but
Raiders kind of the house pet for me now
normally but we'll see how that goes
all right well Raiders are not the play
you're picking right Ramsey's play know
your brand Rams is going alright 90% of
the tickets here at Caesar's Palace
sports book on the Rams so I hate to say
but I do not like your best bet all
right over here to the left of me man
let's see I really do like the bangles
and I really do like that Texans over
but I like this Jason Witten Jersey got
two touchdowns on the season there we go
is it on your fantasy team let me guess
alright I'm gonna come with Texans
Chargers over well I like that bet as
well alright let's head to the sports
week not bad guys Congrats man it's hard
to convince Kelly they did a good job
you know sometimes you get on a hot
streak and you're feeling yourself you
feeling like Michael Jordan game six and
then life has a way of reminding you
that you're not the Michael Jordan of
anything but in this week's Betty
confessional Johnny Manziel got the hot
hand and instead of one of these he
threw up a couple of these
[Music]
sup guys johnnie menzel here about the
first time I've ever rolled dice played
craps I'm in I'm in Cleveland go to the
horseshoe for the first time I'm with
Joe Hayden a couple of other guys from
the Browns at the time I sit down I
don't know how to play at all I don't
know what the numbers are I don't know
what you suppose they hit I don't know
what you do anything
I have $2,500 I sit down I start playing
sit there for about five the next eight
to ten hours just learning how to play
just kind of figuring it out walked out
with over a little over a hundred and
five thousand got paid in bricks on the
spot and pretty much my favorite game to
this day obviously with how it started
but yeah 2500 into into a hundred and
five thousand first time I first time I
ever rolled I when most people complete
a seven hour marathon all they get is a
cookie and a Gatorade but with a hundred
and five grands was a lot of cookies and
a lot of gate arrays and that sounds
like one heck of an after-party were you
invited I was not invited but I do have
a really great Cleveland Horseshoe story
we'll say for another day I can't wait
to hear drew the Chiefs game
send us your betting confessionals for a
chance to be featured on our social
channels speaking of social media it's
time for minds in the public where I'm
gonna answer betting questions sent to
us from the VR audience
first up director Daniel wants to know
would you stay away from a low spread
when a favorite is a lot better of a
team for example the Brant Browns vs.
Rams yes I would stay away why because
it looks like a trap game those short
road favorites are how the book gets
paid every single week if it looks too
good to be true it probably is
next up mint berry crunch asks what are
the odds the Patriots go 62 no or the
Dolphins go ohhh in 16 this is really
interesting because there's been a lot
of chatter around Vegas about either one
of these events happening I think
neither of them happens why the Pats
have tough games at the bills at the
Eagles at the Ravens and versus the
Chiefs I think they lose two out of four
of those for sure and then here's this
dolphin seeing how bad are they there's
still a professional team I still don't
think they're as bad as the Owen 16
Detroit Lions they do play the skins the
Jets and the Bing
at home they will be single-digit dogs
in each and I think they can steal a win
if not two out of that grouping g-man 19
says I cannot go to a game without
betting on it when a Falcons Colts on
Sunday who do you like uh I'm the same
with you I I hate going to games without
any action you got to have something fun
to cheer for my fandom is now dead Thank
You sports betting folks though one in
five straight up and against the spread
and it's last six home openers I know
Matt Ryan on Sunday kind of scared
everybody I was also holding a Falcons
ticket but I'm hoping to see some
improvement from him and Julio Jones
against that cold secondary I like the
Falcons that is it for this week make
sure to send us your questions by
tagging happy hour underscore betting on
social parlez vous parlez pas parler
shout out to greg one of our producers
where i stole that from each week the
bleacher report audience will vote on
twitter for three teams which we will
place a $100 bet on that's the people's
parlay so far this year we are Owen -
but I'm confident that third time's the
charm
and this week the people have chosen the
Chiefs the Patriots and the Cowboys I
can feel Kelly's reaction right out to
the peoples parlay because they're
overwhelming favorites how do you how do
you judge our ticket here Kelly the
people of school like I say every week
you guys are gonna go one in two it's
okay our lives are tough to hit we know
it but if you want a good fade the
people's parlay is it two and four on
the season so wait your what you're
gonna fade the pepper you gonna bet
against the people that's our people
Kelly well I think this is a good segue
into my best bet I'm gonna fade against
the number one team right there you guys
know I love those underdogs and each and
every week I'm trying to give you guys
an underdog that can win outright and
this week that underdog is the Ravens
Ravens are this is one of those points
in time where I'm gonna take the Ravens
with the five and a half because we're
getting points here with an overvalued
team they have the edge on special teams
the defense the old-line they've covered
the last four row games including last
year in Kansas City nobody wants to give
that again
Patrick mahomes I understand but Patrick
mahomes does not play defense and that
is the Chiefs weak point he is going to
utilize again for betting on Lamar
Jackson and the Ravens to keep it closed
Chiefs are on upset alert this Sunday
cabby
do you like my best bet against the
peoples far away well listen I I'm torn
you're my co-host but I also want to
rock with the people and on the peoples
partly we have the Chiefs minus five and
a half Straub this week I'm gonna stay
with the people I hope you land us I
don't hate you guys let's recap all my
picks for week one these are listed in
order of confidence and how many units I
would recommend you bet on each so as
you guys can see the Ravens are my best
bet so they're a three unit play two
units is a nice gap in the middle so we
have some good action on this NFL Sunday
one unit is not really anything I'm
probably gonna get involved in okay we
kill you when you see unit how much is a
unit like I'm what's a unit is a
baseline amount you give you bet on
given any certain wager right so one
unit should be approximately one percent
of your bankroll I never recommend
betting more than five percent at any
point in time so if your bankroll is
like like a thousand bucks
so three units would be a thirty dollar
bet let's say I'm on the Ravens are your
best bet right okay so thirty okay
yeah thirty twenty so that makes sense
it does yeah I hope you guys enjoyed
that the fact that the be are betting
show turned into calculus today but we
can follow along thank you very much for
joining us this show has been presented
by the Caesars Palace sports bar our
journey continues on social at BR
underscore betting follow along to check
my pics and yours see you guys next week
[Music]